Let's talk about the Saudis for a minute.
The elephant under the western carpet,
I mean I understand that in the aftermath
of the oil crisis in the 1970s one of
the things that that dictated American
foreign policy was the desire to maintain
stable oil production.
And,
and I can understand that although
I think it was short sighted,
I can,
I can see the logic in that,
but it's very difficult for me to see
that in any possible way the Saudis can be
regarded as true allies of the West.
And so I don't understand why we have
the relationship that we do have with the
Saudis given,
first of all,
that we're pumping literally trillions
of dollars every about every decade into
the ricotta me.
And then given that they practice
a particularly pernicious form of,
I would say viciously militant Islam
and second or third I guess that is,
is that they're pumping out propaganda
that pushes this Wahhabi viewpoint in
massive doses everywhere in the world.
I mean,
I don't understand,
and maybe this is also part
of your perplexity with
regards to western attitudes
towards,
towards the complex problem of Islam.
I don't understand why the West
doesn't do more to put a stop to that.
And so what are your thoughts about that?
How does it look to you?
I'm a flexed,
I believe that the south would have
booked the United States and other western
listeners and someone has to
come along and break that.
Uh,
I liked it.
I mean I agree with everything can you
said within Saudi Arabia they don't have,
I believe at least three,
four seconds that the royal family who I
believe no one wants to be more secular
and more model,
they want to go down
and then stick larger,
incredibly powerful,
maybe even more powerful than the
Hawaiian side because the clergy in Saudi
Arabia,
yes,
they have the power to put into people's
heads and hearts the Wahhabi doctrine.
And so,
so they are all about in Saudi Arabia,
people who decide what's wrong
moral or other clergy time,
right?
Yeah.
That's powerful.
And then you have the tribe,
the various tribes who obviously
depending on their size,
can empower la Croix royal
familiar or the cloud or both.
There's a dynamic there that
is very interesting to watch.
But in that sense Saudi Arabia
has used and has been George,
it's larger
established.
He will making a legacy.
Saudi Arabia is a few offices,
fewer Medina,
not totally inside the borders
of Saudi Arabia and Tyler.
Yeah and no.
I think we,
the United States and other countries
need to be mad from the Saudi royal family
because they're the
ones who are political,
at least the political
individuals that we deal with her.
We sits you of course for the Tj to demand
and say we need a divorce between the
house of health south and the house of
how hub because these clergy people are
really destroy the planet.
You just,
you have to think through what these
people have done in South Asia,
in Africa,
all over the world.
It's the beauty of
a part of its wealth
to the spread of Islam.
Islam that's pure that way.
That is through institutions and this is,
this is therefore in policy.
We probably could refer
that to us soft house.
That's where the [inaudible] but that if
you look at what is happening with all
these terrorist activities
across the world,
people wanting Shiria back,
all of this,
Saudi Arabia is behind it.
And I think it's time for that.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let me run a theory by you.
It's kind of a two fold theory.
So one is that there's a paternalistic
attitude in the west towards the Saudis
that stems from perhaps events that
were as far back as 100 years ago.
And the journalistic aspect is
to underestimate them as enemies,
right?
Because you say,
well,
we could say,
well we need the oil and we're going to
stabilize it and maybe that we'd rather
not have chaos in Saudi Arabia.
And so a known dictator is
better than unknown chaos.
And I mean we saw some proof of that
perhaps in what happened with Libya,
but so the idea would be there's nothing
sufficiently dangerous about the Saudis
to justify us destabilizing their regime,
especially when we're particularly
dependent on their oil.
And then underneath that would be an
underestimation of the danger of ideas.
And also,
especially when ideas
are combined with money,
it's something like that.
So because the Saudis in some sense I
think are are fighting what you might
regard as a stealth war against the
west and they're doing it by convincing
upcoming generations of the rightness
of their particular viewpoint.
And so they're in it for
the long haul in some sense.
And I think we're radically
underestimating the danger
of that logical walk.
And we are not.
Yup.
Yeah.
Ideological.
We're not,
I mean you have to think of when
the Soviet Union was around,
if we hadn't done anything increase was
if we had only viewed that in economic
terms go in military terms.
And that is
not just telling Rabia this is even Iran.
These countries are waging an ideological
war and we are not because leave,
well it's religion.
Religion is protected and you know,
we don't talk about [inaudible] and that's
one thing we believe we are under the
spell of these be quite charming.
So that's come to attend our universities
that have the embassies do business
with us and that reassure us that
they're more westernized than we are.
You can tell them by how
they treat their women.
Yeah.
So in a way,
I think we,
again,
I just keep going back and say we are
under some sort of spells and at some
point someone has to come
and break that smell.
Yeah.
It's real vogue globalization through,
you know,
uh,
Saudi Arabia opens up to the world.
We really see our eyes,
what was on inside their
own country and insight,
if not just not so do all
of these other countries.
It's the people,
the Canadian people,
Western people and say nose and the
mouth from their governments that they
engage with Saudi Arabia
in a different way.